hello everyone I am Evan Carmichael I
believe that hungry entrepreneur's
deserve help and I got frustrated with
having so much paper in my office my
solution was to use Evernote combined
with a skein snap which is a scanner to
help scan everything in for you and gets
rid of all your paper but now I found an
even easier solution we're just using
Evernote the free app and your cell
phone and then you can scan in all you
receipts important documents agreements
whatever it is that you need to do so
I'm going to take a quick example I'm
going to open up my wallet and you can
see I've got money but I've got a whole
bunch of receipts that I don't want to
have here right I want to try to build a
paperless office I'm going to pull out
one receipt and this is from Costco and
I bought two hotdogs
so not a business receipt but we can use
it for the example I like my hotdogs so
what I'm going to do is put this on the
table I'm going to load up my Evernote
on my my phone here I'm going to go to
my receipts and pretend like this is a
business receipt click on that I'm going
to go new note I'm going to call it
Costco and then I'm going to go to the
camera and just go over it and take a
picture
pictures taken then I'll press ok and
there it is Costco and I'm just going to
click yes now what I'll usually do
instead of taking one receipt at a time
and naming it I'll usually do it by date
so this is July 23rd if I load that up
you'll see a whole bunch of different
receipts that I've just taken pictures
of now what's going to happen is as I go
back I can go back to the front of
Evernote and I can ask it to sync and
it's going to update it to the website
so if I ever need to get access to this
receipt again I could do it from my
phone from a computer from somebody
else's computer from any tablet from a
laptop anywhere you are you can get
access to your receipts and you can
print off a copy if you need to so you
don't actually ever have to keep
physical documents anymore in your
office so now this is the really cool
thing about using Evernote to scanning
your receipts it's finding things if you
keep paper documents everywhere it's
really really hard to find the things
that you're looking for when you need it
so if I'm looking for an agreement I'm
looking for a receipt or looking for a
government document I have everything in
Evernote and it's all full-text
searchable that's the real winner here
so that receipt that I just scanned in I
can find it anytime I want I just have
to go to the search button here at the
bottom and I bought hotdogs so I can go
type in hot oops
hot dog dug click the search button and
we'll go through all my notes to try to
find anytime I've mentioned hot dog I
didn't use it in quotes so it's pulling
up other things but you can see the
first receipt here the first document is
that receipt that I scanned in because I
don't know if you guys can see it here
if it'll zoom in enough for you but it
says reg hot dog here on on the receipt
so we did a full-text search of my
receipts and this is really helpful
again if you ever need to find a receipt
well if you want to take something back
to the store as long as they have the
little barcode scanner they can scan it
in and give you a refund I wouldn't work
here because there's no barcode but so
super helpful so now everything is off
my desk out of my office I don't need to
have filing cabinets every agreement
every time
action every receipt is stored online I
can get access to it from any device
that I have computer phone tablet
somebody else's computer and I've ever
need to go find something it's super
easy because everything is put in put
into a full-text searchable file that
you can carry with you bring to store
show people whatever you need to do
everything is instantly available at
your fingertips so I thought that was
really cool again I was using the scan
snap to start and that's a scanner that
Fujitsu puts out that you can scan all
your receipts and everything and it
comes you know maybe a lot it looks a
little bit nicer than just having this
picture here but this is so much faster
at least I found just snap snap snap
snap pictures are done it auto the cords
all the tax super easy to find and saves
me a lot of time so hopefully it can
save you guys time too good luck if you
guys like the video please give it a
thumbs up below makes gonna do more for
you and if you have questions about this
video or comment I'd love to hear from
you really is the best part of my day
seeing those comments come in even if
you just saying thanks to the video so
thank you guys and I'll hear from you
soon
Cheers